I got a confession this is like my first
celebrity interview ever I'm a little
nervous I just I guess my first question
is how am i doing so far
I I've been thinking about that since I
was a kid like it when you're doing
lightsaber work let's pretend like you
had a real lightsaber because they exist
and every time you did training or
filming like how many times have you
actually hit yourself and amputated of a
body part um oh that's a big secret but
uh me personally yeah never never you're
just that good no I'm just lucky you
only do a jumping spinning kick - yes
yeah I don't think I could get that high
let's try it together huh ready oh is
this better nice I'm gonna like it
hey good man good man nice beard by the
way thank you thank you took me about 15
years ago so yes I've always blue blue
red these are a lot nicer than ones I
believe blue Metzler whoo so you know
about you know I would have taken my arm
all right there's our Facebook ID with
yeah baseball bat you know I know it's
up yeah now push it off now you push me
off and then swipe it me away
[Music]
[Music]
Jedi's glad to have you back nice